happy Valentine's Day that's right it is
Valentine's Day and if you're finding
out right now you're either single or
you're about to be single some guys
watching right now just finding out yeah
it is Valentine's Day as I said or as
it's known at CVS
oh [ __ ] day yeah
an hour ago I ran there and I got my
wife some starbursts and a jar of eczema
lotion I also do my Christmas shopping
there at the last time okay on this
subject of Valentine's Day for
Valentine's Day true story White Castle
has transformed into a sit-down
restaurant with red tablecloths and
champagne served in paper cups yeah it's
the perfect way to tell that special
someone you'll do for now what else is
going on big story nationally today a
Russian spy ship was spotted off the
east coast of the United States yeah
yeah it was here to give former National
Security Advisor Michael Flynn a ride
back home
[Applause]
yes as you all know President Trump's
national security adviser Michael Flynn
has resigned after it was discovered he
lied to Mike Pence yeah evidently he
told pence of course people like you
[Applause]
this is serious for president Trump
though in the wake of the Flynn
resignation Democrats are asking what
President Trump knew what did he know
it's historic it's the first time
anyone's ever accused Ahnold Trump of
knowing too much no one's ever here's
the latest from Senate Republicans
Senate Republicans are trying to pass
legislation that would make it legal for
mentally ill people to buy guns yes yeah
Republicans said mentally ill people
have a right to one gun for each of the
voices in their head
[Applause]
television news ABC has cast its first
african-american woman as the
Bachelorette it's all part of the
bachelorettes new motto chlamydia is
colorblind and trouble with that one
didn't you think about it you'll get
over it
[Laughter]
you